good morning believe nation today's
message is change the rules over to you
Geno Auriemma you might have five
players on offense
and we'll have four players on defense
so we're trying to guard your five with
our four which is really hard then once
they get the hang of that we'll put
another player on your team now uf6 and
we have four now that's really hard and
with the great teams that I've had we'll
give you eight and one five that's
really really hard so whenever they get
comfortable with being able to do
something we just change the equation up
a little bit and make it really really
hard some players coach like they got
seven guys we only got five what do you
expect well you know what those guys are
never going to be good and then the
great teams that I've had they have
seven and we have five and we beat them
and they go coach really that's the best
you can do only seven you better put
another one out there they're the ones
that are going to be great so we're
always looking to do things like that
change the score change the rules as we
go along and they don't like it because
as soon as they get close I change the
rules you know you put the caret in the
minute they get close I move it and they
get close I move it again and then some
just goes forget it I'm not going and
then the other ones they get like real
close to the caret real close and then
they put your hands on your throat choke
you and take the cap and they're the
ones that are going to be champions I
think this message applies especially to
entrepreneurs because we get to set our
own rules that's why we're not working
for the man that's why we quit working
at that company because we wanted to
create our own set of rules and live our
own life one of the challenges that I
find for a lot of entrepreneurs is we
quickly then create our own schedule we
quickly think
create a box that we live in and the
more we get into business the more we
box ourselves in instead of continually
being able to break free and explore the
things that make us come alive so if you
ever find yourself asking yourself why
don't I have more time to go on vacation
why don't I have more time to spend time
with my family why am I not spending
more time doing media or talking to
customers why am I not spending more
time going to trade shows or conferences
remember you created a business that
created that schedule for you and if you
want to go out and change it you can
it's inside your control it's your
company break the rules so my question
today for you guys today is how are you
breaking the rules leave it in the
comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso